valorant has got a clone and i'm not
talking about a couple of university
kids making a crappy knock-off this game
is made by a major company and when you
compare it to valorum it looks like one
of the biggest rip-offs we've seen in
years ages weapons abilities maps
they've taken it all we're going to take
a look at it now and then answer the
question that is on everybody's lips why
the hell haven't they been sued off the
face of the planet
all right so later on in the video i'm
going to be talking about how even
though this story is insane it does
happen more than you expect when it
undoubtedly happens again you're gonna
need to make sure you are subscribed to
the score esports and that way you'll
never miss out on game cloning news ever
again
easy
so at the start of august a video
started being shared there was
advertising the closed beta test for a
new mobile game project m before we get
into how exactly riot has had their
homework copied here i think it's
probably best if you just watch a clip
from this video you know to see if you
notice anything familiar
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'm not kidding it's almost
laughable and the comment section didn't
exactly get the warm reception that
project m was hoping for people were
quick to point out the recognizable
abilities guns and kill effects they
knew and loved from riot's latest fps
smash hit valorent and by now some of
you may be wondering where you've heard
the name project m before well that was
the name of a popular super smash bros
mod released in 2013 that attempted to
make smash bros brawl more like smash
bros melee by making the gameplay faster
and more technical so this valorant
ripoff doesn't even have an original
name in fact some of you may remember
that when valorem was in development it
was code named project ah
[Music]
okay so let's take a deeper look at the
game itself then as you can see the
whole interface is almost identical from
the player icons at the top of the kill
feed to the display at the bottom even
the mini map looks the same the weapons
loadout looks exactly the same too we
see guns that look identical the shorty
the classic the frenzy and the phantom
to name but a few all they seem to have
done is give the guns slightly different
names to the valorum originals which is
weird it's like copying your mates
homework at school and thinking you'll
get away with it because you cross your
t's slightly differently otherwise it's
like the exact same thing moving on to
the characters now they're basically all
like weird siblings of the valor and
agents you've come to love meet elixir
for example elixir is basically sage she
can heal her allies just like sage and
yes her old resurrects allies in fact
the only thing that's different from
sage is her camouflage ability which is
basically just a combo of jet smoke with
the shape of cipher's trap if you're a
raider main well let me introduce you to
blood raider his blind works exactly the
same way as rayner's and his hardened
shell ability is like rayner's dismiss
granting brief invincibility and of
course the ultima is reiner's ultimate
giving a frenzy boost of blood raiders
firing equip and reload speeds the list
just goes on this video could honestly
just be me sitting here going through
every character and comparing their
abilities to ballarat but we'd honestly
be here all day corporate needs you to
find the differences between this
picture
and this picture
they're the same picture
so i think it's safe to say we've
established this as being as close to a
clone as you can possibly get now i know
some of you might be sitting there
saying oh but hang on isn't valerian a
clone of cs go haha
well
come on let's be reasonable here
ballarat may have taken 13 rounds of
tactical shooting and bomb defusal from
cs go but it's done more than enough to
call itself a distinct game the same can
be said with league of legends and dota
there's inspiration and then there's
just straight up duplication project m
seems to look like the latter okay so
let's tackle the next question you're
probably thinking how the [ __ ] are they
getting away with this well this isn't
the first time that the games creators
chinese company netties have done
something like this take a look at one
of their other games for example
creative destruction and just tell me
what this reminds you of
that's right apart from the fact it says
you are the star at the end of the game
instead of victory royale it's literally
just fortnite another good example here
is area f2 the game that was accused of
being a rainbow six siege clone in may
2020 we covered the story of ubisoft
suing apple and google for their release
of area f2 a game which ubisoft said was
a copy of siege well a few days after
they sued apple and google took the game
down but that's not where the story ends
in august 2020 it was announced that f2
will be making a return under a new
publisher
nettie's the same company behind project
m
yeah so this all comes down to
intellectual property law in china
basically it's a lot more lacks than
what most western countries are used to
essentially chinese copyright law does
allow companies to copyright individual
assets of their work but not the fixed
form of the work as a whole what this
means is that as long as the assets in
the game are reskinned or modified a
little bit here and there it's basically
safe under chinese law perhaps one of
the most bizarre examples of this came
in 2014 when a chinese company called
300 heroes not only ripped off league of
legends it also straight up threw shrek
in there as a playable character because
if you're gonna copy other people's work
yeah just throw shrek in there as well
on top of all this there really isn't
much written into chinese law that
allows companies to fight intellectual
property theft within the chinese legal
system while there have been some
changes that improve a company's ability
to do this it's clearly not enough
because as you can see we've got games
like project m coming out for companies
based outside of china it's essentially
a game of whack-a-mole sure they might
be able to take down one game through
the legal system but it's only a matter
of time before another one pops right
back up project m is a riot game riot's
parent company is 10 cent 10 cent is the
number one gaming company in china and
nettie's is number two although 10 cent
will undoubtedly be pissed off with
their main rival creating project m
they've also been accused of cloning
games themselves their wechat game
titled tiau yi thiao was accused of
being a clone of a french mobile game
called bottle flip the point is this
type of stuff is rampant in china
companies clone games and then have
their own games cloned it's a bit of a
mess even though 10 cent are the
ultimate owners of valorum they know as
well as anyone how difficult it is to
stop this kind of stuff happening in
china as of yet we've heard nothing from
riot or tencent on the mata but that may
change in the not too distant future
because they have something very big
coming up valorum mobile it was
announced on june 2nd 2021 on the
anniversary of valorance launch the year
before there's currently not too much
information about the game or its
release date but whenever it comes out
nettie's got their project m clone out
first and 10 cent won't be happy about
that will they actually do anything
about it though we'll have to wait and
see maybe one day nettie's will even
clone sentinels tens hiko
a lot of them and that would be a story
to cover
what would i do if i had a clone if i
had a clone i would probably just
divide up the tasks that we had to do
i'd probably do some music with them you
know i think it would be good our voices
would like
go together really well
because they're the same voices and i
play guitar and i make him play
something weird like
trombone
yeah